nos dicen que los administradores de la
escuela están considerando cambiar el
reglamento realizaron una encuesta a un
grupo de estudiantes miembros del
personal y padres de familia sobre si
estaban de acuerdo con el nuevo
reglamento la siguiente gráfica de
mosaicos resume sus resultados y nos
preguntan cuáles de estos enunciados se
ven reflejados en la gráfica de mosaicos
pausa este vídeo y trata de resolverlo
por tu cuenta
escoge cuáles de estas opciones se
pueden inferir a partir de la gráfica
pueden ser más de una de las que tienes
que escoger
bueno pues trabajemos juntos en esto
antes de ver las opciones veamos que
podemos interpretar de la gráfica lo que
hace esta gráfica a diferencia de las
gráficas de barras segmentadas es que
usa el ancho para mostrarnos cuántos
estudiantes cuántos miembros del
personal y cuántos padres de familia se
muestrearon aunque cuanto se encuestaron
podemos ver que más de la mitad de las
personas encuestadas fueron estudiantes
y que la cantidad de padres y de
personal se ve similar en términos de
quienes están de acuerdo con el nuevo
reglamento esos están dibujados de azul
claro ok pero parece que es poco
probable que los estudiantes estén de
acuerdo se ve que es bastante probable
que los miembros del personal estén de
acuerdo porque la mayoría del personal
está de acuerdo aquí vemos que la
mayoría del personal está de acuerdo y
los padres están de los dos lados y
ahora sí veamos cuáles de estos
enunciados son consistentes con lo que
acabamos de observar los padres de
familia apoyan el nuevo reglamento con
menor probabilidad que los demás
no eso no es cierto los que aprueban el
nuevo reglamento con menor probabilidad
son los estudiantes por aquí ellos
definitivamente son los que tienen la
menor probabilidad el porcentaje de los
estudiantes que aprueban el nuevo
reglamento es el menor así es que esta
opción no es correcta
más de la mitad de los encuestados son
estudiantes esto sí parece ser el caso
porque si nos fijamos en todo este ancho
que es el total de los encuestados y lo
comparamos con este ancho el de los
estudiantes podemos ver que abarca más
de la mitad aunque hoy parece que es el
cincuenta y tantos por ciento o incluso
el 60 por ciento así es que me gusta
esta opción y finalmente hubo más
alumnos que contestaron que no que
miembros del personal y padres de
familia combinados pues observemos
cuántos estudiantes contestaron que no
los que contestaron que no están de
color azul oscuro son esta área por acá
podemos colorear toda esta área
y los miembros del personal y padres de
familia que contestaron que no
combinados es esta otra área por acá
y se ve que el total de los estudiantes
que contestaron que no toda esta área
por acá es mucho más grande que el área
de acá
por lo que también me gusta esta opción